good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how to reinvent
yourself rule number one is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
although to the end of some special
bonus clips also as people are talking
if they say something that really really
resonates with you please leave it in
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
enjoy
[Music]
you have to reinvent yourself if the
person you are today is not allowing you
to get to where you want to get to you
don't cry about it
you don't whine about it don't waste
energy because you only have so much of
it what you do is say I've got as much
as I can get with what I have I've got
I've got as far as I can go with who I
am and what curly and I'm taking where I
gotta be
so I gotta be a bit myself so you say
what you mean you say reinvent yourself
I'll be Michael Jordan that's why I move
through my Championships is first
Hindley really doesn't wanna challenge
it in second but no no no it's in my
seven years right seven years to make
that dream become a reality
so the first fight yoga he put up a lot
of points the other works like you wanna
dunk contest you're right the first
might put up like 62 against Boston in
the playoffs and see your loss that's
right Michael Jordan I'm
press to Shuster nightmares he had the
t-shirt right everybody doing but guess
what that might be joined in with any
Championships I'm standing here in my
pants 462 the white neck and of them
have cool to my action why ruin the old
started the Mike loved that Michael
Jordan with my championship and so guess
what I came to do my had to relive
himself and so it's to my timetable a
difference it is for Allah restart the
past he's going to work out just a dumb
way they've got a little sixteen but a
jet you go to the wagon way and guess
what the new mind didn't know what he
said you know one good up [ __ ] - I'm
getting discharged
you know said I'm doing all kind of
shooting I'm scoring I would entitled
I'm gonna Championships no he didn't say
that he says I do that because I mean I
is not change to that one sorry--but my
son so he didn't give up heating quick
in Wien bitter son he's done playing
defense man he's got passive head shoot
instead of just dunk and guess what
remember one - two - three - four - five
- six seven ship and many of us believe
that in our time / daddy baby
eight times its oyster boy he said
number one you gotta reinvent yourself
right if you're not where you wanna be
don't worry don't give up and do not
give the goals accomplished you're not
making your dream - don't quit reinvent
yourself entrepreneurs who have authored
a product or a process that isn't
working today have to make the bold step
of reinventing themselves I talk about
it all the time how over the course of
my life whether it was at 12 years old
or 18 years old or 25 years old or even
today I'm constantly working to reinvent
myself I'm not any different than a
package on a shelf people have to feel
that it's relevant they have to see the
warning labels they have to understand
the contents it has to be appealing it
has to provide value to people and so
when an entrepreneur has a product or a
process that they've authored and
they're not willing to change it then
they're going to end up like Circuit
City or Montgomery Ward or Sears or Fiat
or whatever these brands are that don't
exist anymore right every single company
in this country today if they're not
evolving they're dying and I don't know
why an entrepreneur would think that
they would be exempt from that process
I'm not interested in their ego I'm not
interested in their pride I'm not
interested in their feelings I'm
interested in their business being
successful and so I think not only does
their business have to do it but but we
as entrepreneurs have to do it as well
the breakthrough happens by conditioning
your mind every day by feeding it a role
model or story it's putting yourself in
a pink state when you follow through by
getting physically strong it's creating
a little ritual of doing a little bit
each day and then you get momentum but
the most important thing of all is what
we start out with why absolutely why is
it a must for you it doesn't have to be
here against the wall but it has to be
something you're hungry for because the
only difference in people is hunger and
if you're not hungry
get around people that are hungry and
something will hit you you watch a
conversation you get around people are
doing better and all of a sudden you
start going my life sucks I remember I
went through a guy in LA it's one of the
most multi-billionaire guys I'll never
forget and I lived in the Del Mar Castle
I was really proud that was like the
symbol of me having picked myself from
being poor to providing for my family
this great place built some castles in
Europe overlooking the ocean not far
from you and I went this guy's house
he's billionaire he took me down to the
wine cellar I don't even drink wine what
did this whole thing at the end of the
night I was depressed I lived in the Del
Mar tenement as far as I was concerned I
really was I was like I live in a crappy
place and all my standards changed all
sudden I wasn't willing to settle for
living that all of a sudden my back was
to the wall in a different way because
as a man I knew was capable more so
people can change their standard by
getting around where it's better people
can change their standard by getting
associated what's true like the bills
they got to solve the problems they got
to do it or they can do it because
they're excited because there's
something really want to take on
everyone's different but they got to
find the why and they got to come up
with some daily rituals to get them
going and just do a step at a time
that's what you get momentum
baseball players right this is what I
tell these guys you were this close to
going to the lead you making your dreams
become a reality
do yourself a favor don't sabotage
yourself honestly so we gotta hear me
I'm telling read it yourself but I
didn't read it yourself
I'm told don't sabotage yourself what do
you mean that I tell my boys listen to
me if you're making let it be because we
have injury not because you got kicked
off the team because activity you were
where you suppose that sabotaged
yourself right the door sweep in right
when you supposed to be a prime that's
appetizing mr. DUI don't get kicked off
the team because you've broken some
school policy also cheaper that's
advertising yourself and you keep your
job
let me be within a hundred and twenty
percent somebody was better or something
happened to you physically and so we're
gonna say it again
we taught yourself you say me know
sometimes I sell some suits buy them
don't do it man when you took a selfie
with your father crying look at the
clock and it's five o'clock I'm sorry
by pushing too soon don't start our
class late
don't start I'll get there on time it's
not about the visitor Berger Brewster
then you can take ten minutes of your
time
if you get on time you already play
upside of tide your success when you get
your input on your heart put all your
mind put all your soul you put your mind
you gotta be where you gotta see and
then she can walk away feeling good nor
that you put any God you put 120 percent
so don't sabotage yourself by hanging
out with the wrong people remember birds
of a feather flock together
he goes to the pigs though they got
together lady I was to get a ship or a
team remember today sure take man today
is the beginning of a brand new life
today is the beginning of making all
your dreams become a reality
I started somebody who's homeless I
started from the bottom and by God's
grace
up to the top and so if I can do it you
can do it listen to me you gotta
understand the only way to the storm
kind of joy
if you enter someone come enjoy if you
come after storm kind of joy cuz ain't
about the storm it's about your heart
it's about your mind and spot you ever
everybody goes through so I listen to me
as et was blowing up a mother-in-law got
diagnosed with terminal cancer and they
told she was folder died last December
and she still living another one fast
turn while horrible YouTube she was
dying
you hear what I'm saying to you life
happens but when the time keep going my
biggest hit top man when things get
tough the tough get going and I like my
man tick typically best Jake said he
brought through trials and tribulations
the best thing you can do is Edward the
worst thing you can do is pay use it to
your advantage
why because if you've ever said that
here with me what you know what that
even with Eagle paws best when they're
storms when there is wind because what
well what it does it uses to win from
the storm to push it in elevate and so
I'm irritated
I don't you put your trials are with
your traditions are outraged like that
airplane give beyond pop don't worry
about your hands are like pigeons
and that's what business can only fly so
high and so you don't have to worry
about people and circumstances and
situations you just fly to a place that
they can culture you elevate yourself
you fly to a place that nobody else can
go to those who are willing to be
successful my career my entire career is
a study in reinvention you know I
started out as a comedian that was it I
never planned on hosting a radio show
hosting a game show or hosting a daytime
talk show I never did writing books none
of it making movies
none of it reinvention happens when you
diversify your guilt there lies your
greatest secret for success
you've got to discover your gift and
when you discover it you got to soak it
you got to wring it out man
you got to diversify it most of us only
have one talent but do you know that
that's all you need mine happens to be
to take information and immediately
transfer it into other kinds of
platforms now when I was younger I
actually thought that I could only do
that with comedy but as I've gotten
older I discovered through
diversification that it was a little bit
more than that that I could also take
information immediately transfer it into
inspiration I could turn it into
motivation I can offer it as guidance so
now sitting on a talk show I actually
have something to talk about all the
failed marriages I got something to talk
about to be at homeless I got something
to talk about being dead broke I got
something to talk about having bad
credit tax problems I got something to
talk about whatever hole you've been
here not just about drug myself through
it but I came out of all of it because I
was not afraid to diversify my gift even
the book act like a lady think like a
man it was all about me diversifying
again okay I had take
two failed marriages and I had taken the
love for my daughters and I combined
those things I taught my daughters what
I knew about men now little did I
discover that I had a little over four
million daughters in this country
cousins and nieces and stuff like that
who needed that same information and and
that was a huge part for me to take that
information and turn it into a book that
turned it into a mega star movie - and
it produced a lot of things for me but
it also helped a lot of people one of
the other tricks for reinventing
yourself is not letting your background
become a limitation if you take that
background that you're from and never
let it define you but allow it to
redefine you all that stuff works for
the good do you understand that you
needed everything that's happened to you
to happen to you in the exact order that
has happened in order for you to be the
person that you are today all that
failing and getting over you need it all
at that so it's good to be steeped in
the traditions of your gift but don't
get stuck in them look if your gift is
bacon don't assume that there's only one
way to do it if you bake bake but you
can't just bake for people you know bake
for people you don't know your musician
let yourself explore other types of
music I got to tell you example the
roots who play on Jimmy Fallon show they
steeped in hip-hop but they're also
great musicians so what they do is they
take all of that talent and now guess
what hip-hop jazz R&B classic pop rock
they didn't just get stuck on here but
I'm doing hip-hop that's it now they do
whatever LL Cool J hip-hop more on the
top actors on TV today Queen Latifah
hip-hop big active right now you get it
Jerry Seinfeld nothing but a comedian on
the biggest actors on TV today remember
you can win if you're not afraid to
reinvent yourself stop getting stuck
just go ahead and give a try you never
know so how do we cultivate this idea of
kind of reinventing but it's more like
innovative ideas for ourselves to create
something new how do we cultivate these
innovative ideas well let me ask you a
question when you switched into I don't
know did you play handball since you
were a kid no okay so so how did you
decide I'm gonna be an Olympic level
athlete in handball sure and what did
you do what was the first thing you did
I saw it on TV I watched the 2008
Olympics I was sleeping on my sister's
couch still with the I just got my cast
off from playing football from the
surgery and I Washington Olympics and
instantly I just had a new idea I said
that's something I want to do I just
like I'm gonna play on the USA so
something something stirred in sighs you
like you felt it like a dream a new
dream Chris created and that happens to
people I don't want to say every day but
like once a year couple times a year
once a month that you feel that you
don't always pursue everything right I'm
sure there's many things you would like
to do that you don't pursue you know the
bandwidth for it's not the right timing
or whatever yeah but you already had
training as an athlete you know okay
this is another sport this is something
where I it's like almost like a back
door to the Olympics because or enjoy
the US team because who else would think
to do the one else's point right yeah so
it seems like an old man swore I could
probably squeeze in here and get good
enough okay so what's your what you do
next so next I started researching I
went online instead of researching like
USA handball handball teams in Ohio
there was nothing in Ohio then I said
okay where are the teams in the country
and and I started looking at what are
the best teams because if I'm going to
learn as quickly I need to learn from
the best so I learned that the New York
team had won the national championships
over the last few years so I was like
okay when I make enough money I'm going
to go to New York City and learn from
these this play these players his team
and for about the next year I was like
well how many they do that because I
have no money I'm broke on my sister's
couch
that's when linked instead of kind of
opening up for me and I started to make
like a few hundred bucks a month
teaching LinkedIn so I said okay when I
make enough money doing this I'm gonna
leave Ohio and go to New York City to
like see what this is like and by the
way when you were in New York City it's
not like you stopped making money on
LinkedIn no no these things are
interweaving all of your weaving yes so
I about a year later year and a half
later I started really making a lot of
money like just kind of started
happening everything started to unfold
and happened after a lot of action
taking and so I moved to New York City
for a month now the whole
this year year and a half no one will
respond to me on the USA national team
for like the headquarters no one will
respond to me at the New York team I
would email people out call numbers no
one would get back to me how are you
getting better during this time I was
just training as an athlete but I was I
still haven't played handball yet but I
still had this idea of like I need to go
in at least explored so I don't regret
not trying to see if I could make this I
was like at least I got to go and try it
so I can kind of eliminate it from my
mind as something I want to do or don't
want to do in the future but if I for me
personally I know that if I think about
something I want to do it if I don't at
least explore it I'll think about a
first of my life and I'll regret not
trying not going to go so so I said okay
no one's getting back to me anywhere I'm
emailing people every month I'm trying
to call people every month no one's
getting back to me so I say screw it I'm
gonna go to Newark for a month I had a
couple speaking gigs in New York for
like LinkedIn something and add some
social media conferences and I was like
I'm just gonna go stay for the month I'm
going to show up at their practice
because they had the practice address of
where they practice on the website for
the New York team so you so you got
ready I got right by constantly raining
yep and then you just you fired that's
it I just showed up and I got a show to
the projects when I said they were
playing cuz no one picked up or gave you
information to do they'll give me
permission I showed up and the first day
I got there I was the only American on
who was in the court and it was all
these former professional players in
Europe who now moved to New York and
kind of like live and play for fun
so as a white man you're basically the
minority I was minority I was like they
barely spoke English I was just like
this outsider and I got there and I go
hey guys my name is Luis I'm here from
Ohio and my my goal is to make the
Olympics and play at the USA national
team and they just all started laughing
and then I just showed up every single
week I ended up moving to New York I
didn't go back to Ohio I stayed there
for the next year and a half and nine
months later I made the USA team but I
was there every single week practicing
and just like learning and taking action
so so what you did was exemplifies
something that and this isn't original
to me I'll describe where where it comes
from
but I call in my book I call this
you reinvent yourself by finding your
plus/minus equal so your plus was all
these people you wanted to be around the
best in the world better than me right
so you could learn from them so you have
to find your plus and at first they're
they're virtual you might be watch
youtube videos to them you read books
about them you study things that they
write or photographs they take or videos
they shoot so then then they became real
for you because you actually join them
and start hanging around them then you
have to find your equals because if you
just crushed every day in a game of
handball you it's gonna be hard for you
you need lessons but then you need
people who challenge you yes so people
who can say oh I got that one more point
off him I feel challenged and you get
better better and you can measure your
results and there were people there they
were like that who are on the team of
beginners so alright so you found you
found your peer group you find your new
cohort and then you find um it's almost
a bad word for but you call the I call
the the - which is people you could
teach I don't know if this was like you
know a catalyst for your reinvention but
ultimately you play people in handball
that you're a lot better than then you
could teach them and that solidifies
your learning right so and that's almost
every reinvention you know you and I
have both had hundreds of people on our
podcast they've all reinvented
themselves and I bet you in every single
case there's a plus/minus
equal yeah so that happens of all them
like I talked to anybody from from a
rapper to a huge entrepreneur like a
billionaire entrepreneur they've all had
their plus minus equal what are some of
the steps that you guide people through
of how they can reinvent themselves
well again everybody wants to sort a
quick magic pill and I think in the time
that we've got available here what I
really want to do is guide people into
some areas of focus that can really add
some value and the first one that I
always pick is about asking better
questions questions direct our focus and
if you're not directing your own focus
I've got news for you there's a lot of
people that pay a lot of good money to
Madison Avenue to figure out how to do
it for you
and yeah and that's and that's not the
life you want to live being programmed
by other people's agendas and you know I
like in the mind to a compass needle
yeah it can only point in one direction
at a time
and the challenge is just like if we
take a needle of magnetize it like back
in high school yeah you take a magnet a
power source and you align it and keep
stroking that needle in one continuous
direction so that needle aligns to the
magnetic field and becomes coherent
pointed at all of the ions point in one
direction it becomes magnetized now our
mind is very similar yeah if we are open
to unconsciously being programmed which
unfortunately as human beings we are you
know we wear a 24/7 constant adaptation
machine now our mind and our body now we
understand the body part that's easy now
the physical side of life everybody gets
because they have experiential evidence
off now your body will adapt if you put
it in Donald's or if you put it in the
gym it doesn't mind it will adapt
accordingly
yeah that's its job but our mind is far
more programmable far quicker than our
body and if the magnet the strong force
is constantly magnetizing us is usually
the media and our peer group and if
those two aren't optimal then you know
we're going to be sucked along for the
ride and don't really
magnetize our true north for ourselves
so by asking better questions well it
does it shift the direction of that
needle now the challenge is you can only
do that for 10 percent of the time that
you're conscious or sleeping away
because how most people are 90 percent
of the time that's why when we're
driving to work we can't remember the
last two kilometers on the freeway that
what happened but now if if we focus on
being able to magnetize or take charge
of which direction a compass needle is
pointing we can have a chance to start
reinventing ourselves because otherwise
yeah again you're going to be drifting
especially in that 90 percent at the
time when we do things out of habit
unconsciously that compass needle drifts
back to its precondition magnetic north
and most the time that doesn't serve us
and whether its media conditioned paper
conditioned gear Society condition
something look out of your window
there's not many examples who who we
really want to emulate and become the
surround us on a day to day basis so you
know the first question is yeah or the
first step is ask better questions you
and yet what what ignites you you know
what what causes you to come from a
place of wanting to really give your
gift not surviving today as well because
you've got a mortgage to make not take
the path of certainty which if for
entrepreneurs if they haven't figured it
out yet as I'm sure you let them know as
well yeah there is no certainty in life
now so the ability to handle uncertainty
is one of the core characteristics of an
entrepreneur and so to be able to do
that ask yourself bad questions now what
what resources do I have that I'm not
using yet great question then because
it'll start you looking in different
areas now this is one of the best things
about the human brain is if you ask the
question it'll give you the answer the
challenge is most of us ask lousy
questions you know why does this always
happen to me and it'll give you an
answer it's programmed to you right
because you're worthless because you
deserve it because you're not smart
enough at all so by asking better
questions we can search for better
answers that's really the first place to
start I love it
is there a series of questions that you
recommend everybody ask themselves we
kind of regardless of their situation so
the you know what ignites me what what
gives me passion what resources do I
have that I'm not currently using or
some that you mentioned are there others
that you recommend people kind of get
into the habit of asking themselves yes
and it really ties into what I call
really that the next part of getting
into reinventing who you are and that is
to check your why you know we're driven
by reasons as human beings yeah
everybody does things for reasons now
that may not be your reasons may not be
my reasons but we do things for reasons
most of the time unfortunately we do
very little out of logical reasons now
we do a fair amount out of passion but
most of what we do when we do out of
habits and those habits are formed based
upon the repetitive questions we tend to
ask ourself which usually is suboptimal
and so if you were to ask questions that
elicited your reason why and here's what
I found in the three decades of being an
entrepreneur now that is almost
universal consistent if your Y is
focused on you or not powerful you're
not present you don't have the ability
to dig deeper than you could unless it
was rather than if your why is focused
on something greater than you and yeah
we can see this in evidence everywhere I
give a classic example you take the New
York of the Boston Marathon or not boss
thinks it's more Pro but say new your
Americans are gold for a lot of people
in their fitness sort of the resolutions
and for those that haven't read American
before it's a good goal takes a lot of
training you know I've run crazy stuff
before and it's not easy if you're not a
professional athlete so if you take a
New York you know 35,000 people lining
the streets cheering you on the amount
of people that run the New York Marathon
for the first time not the people that
do it for fun either as an athlete on a
regular basis but for the first time
there is way more percentage of those
people that complete the marathon that
are running for something else not
themselves not their ego not the medal
not significance not the bragging rights
there to support somebody they love in
memory of somebody they cared about to
raise money for a cause they believed in
something beyond themselves and that's
because those that are running for
themselves most of those quit before the
day of the marathon yeah it's a lot to
dig deep when you're just looking at
going out of ego so question is that ask
you you have to reevaluate your why and
most people's why by default is grounded
in a an area that really is fear driven
what if I fail therefore my why for
doing this is because I think it's going
to give me the best chance of success
not because I'm passionate about it not
because it's giving my gift to the world
not because it's something I've always
want it to do
so asking questions like you know if I
knew it was impossible to fail what
would I do then it removed the fear of
failure away and open up possibility
thinking I want it'll do it'll start
getting you in touch with what inspires
you what lights you up what gives you
that that lift not the motivational
factor which is usually avoiding pain
and needs a willpower to get you through
getting up at 5:00 a.m. when it's cold
inspiration you don't need that
motivation motivation is a fuel tank in
a car
out needs topping up inspirations of
deeper wellspring you know asking
questions like if I could only spend my
life doing one thing what would it be
now and and start turning yourself into
that that passion center the a lot of
the time we've blown bars around to
imprison it through not having to face
the possibility of failure and therefore
admit to ourselves we're not enough
which is usually what I see with so many
entrepreneurs that are burning
themselves out there running patterns of
chasing things that they think will give
them the success that will validate them
in the eyes of others whether it's their
parents their business studies teacher
their elder brother who they perceive
that always trying to be in the shadow
of it doesn't matter we've all got our
reasons whereas if you're independent of
what I call swimming in goop geoo P the
good opinion of other people I have
muscular and there life swimming in goop
and it's a sticky nasty smelly mess that
will lead you to a fast track to
mediocrity in no way and so if you can
escape there the good opinion of other
people and stand proud in your truth
that win lose or draw I'm not taking it
with me now the only people that tried
that with the Egyptians and what
happened 3,000 years later we dug it up
installer and I'm here to make the time
I've got count I'm here to make a
difference I'm here to give my gift and
now you can only do that with the
freedom of being independent of the fear
of not being enough or the fear of
having to adapt myself consistently like
a chameleon to fit the pictures of what
I think other people should see me as
rather than say listen yeah I respect
where you're at we're always going to
see things differently because that's
who we are as human beings that self I'm
in my truth and I'm walk-in this way no
one's talking me out of it
and providing that nobody's less than
because you craft their path you know
there's a moral basis to that then yeah
swing the bat with a smile and strike
out a hit a homerun but swing the bat so
my quick take on reinventing yourself is
that it needs to be a constant this is
just one thing that every now and then
you reinvent yourself you are constantly
evolving and changing as a human being
and the things that you do what's
scheduled into your calendar on a day to
day basis needs to change and evolve as
you
changing evolve I am a extremely rigid
scheduled person if you look at my
calendar it's packed full of stuff that
I have to do every single week and I
love that schedule but at the same time
I'm very hyper focused and aware of
where I feel like things are out of
whack if I feel like I need to spend
more time on my youtube-channel I'm
being pulled in that direction or I need
to spend more time with my wife and
being pulled over here or I need to
spend more time at trying to dance salsa
and I'm pulled this way or I need to
spend more time as a father and I pulled
that way
I'm constantly analyzing and adjusting
and then changing making modifications
in the schedule to support what I'm
currently feeling and I think too many
people your schedule is out of whack
with your priorities maybe when you
first set up your schedule maybe when
you first up your business everything
was in alignment here's what I want to
do here my goals here's what's important
to me here's my priorities okay great
I'm going to create a schedule that's
going to focus my efforts on achieving
those goals amazing as your priorities
change as life happens to you you need
to adjust your schedule accordingly or
you're going to be unhappy you're going
to be dissatisfied you're going to
constantly feeling a pull to go over
here but you feel stuck here and as long
as it feels stuck here you're never
going to be happy and too many people
are too afraid to then make that change
as an entrepreneur you have the ultimate
freedom be able to create the schedule
that you want right if you're not an
entrepreneur yet stop blaming other
people it's not your bosses fault that
you can't do what you want it's not your
parents father your wife or husbands
fault it's not your kids fault it's not
your friends fault
it's nobody's fault is your fault you're
not doing the thing that you want to do
it's nobody else's fault but yourself
own it accept it and start making some
changes as soon as you feel like you're
being pulled somewhere that you want to
go try this thing out that it's calling
to you then you need to make an
adjustment in your schedule to allow for
it even if it's a temporary thing maybe
it's to learn salsa dancing maybe you go
when you have a great time with that
first costume and keep doing it maybe
you take that first class and say you
know what that's not for me
and you pull back that's okay what's not
okay is the regret what's not okay is
continuing to think of this idea that
you have continued to wish you had more
time to spend on this thing that's way
over here and you stay stuck here
because until you find out
you're going to constantly live in
regret and it's going to get worse and
worse and worse and worse the more that
you want this and you're stuck here it's
going to get worse
you get increasingly unhappy and so for
me it's not about getting so unhappy
that you have to make this huge change
it's constantly adjusting what you do
constantly adjusting your priorities
constantly adjusting your schedule and I
strongly encourage you guys to whenever
you feel like something is out of whack
on the business side on the personal
side on the development side or whatever
it is you feel like you're being pulled
to do something else other than what
you're doing right now find a time to
adjust your schedule and make it happen
it's on you to do it nobody's coming to
safety this is your responsibility to
live your life to be the best version of
you and that happens when you follow
that intuition and you find out because
finding out and getting the know and
getting a failure and getting you know
understand that that's not for you
finding out is way better than never
finding out finding out and losing is
way better than never finding out so do
it
so thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Jude silvera
asked me to so if there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in the next edition of
believe life please leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'm also super curious to find out
what are the clips resonated the most
with you what did you learn today that
you're going to immediately apply to
your life or to your business please
leave it in the comments below and I'm
going to join in the discussion finally
I want to give a quick shout out to
Torsten Torsten thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word it really really really means a lot
to me I loved seeing that picture of you
holding up so thank you for posting it
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much loved have an
amazing day and I'll see you soon
my question how can I go about
projecting myself as a writer first and
a teacher second
what business steps can I take to make
this transformation thank you for all
you do Christina all right so Christina
we got some good answers for you today
there's actually three very simple very
effective things that you can do right
now to make that transformation and make
it happen fast
the first one is speak it so words have
tremendous power all you got to do next
time you find yourself at a cocktail
party just say you're a writer first so
anytime you introduce yourself talk
about writing talk about your books talk
about everything else before you start
staying you're a teacher and that's
going to make a huge difference so I'm
what we like to say is just do it just
do it just do it Christina number two
number two you want to write it so all
language that goes out to the world
think about this what is your email
signature say what is your business card
say what about any social media profile
the very first thing that you should
have is in gang gang writer so if you
don't have writer as the first thing
listed on all of your written
paraphernalia go and make that change
right now
I'll wait do it did you just do it okay
good
number three and this is the most
important one of all is be it you have
to write as much as you can so if you
don't have a blog I would highly suggest
you start blogging perhaps journaling
will be more your thing but just really
be the writer that you actually are and
it becomes pretty simple if you're doing
something habitually you're writing
every day you're putting out blog post
you're publishing more books naturally
it's going to be the first thing that
pops out of your mouth do you think
people are screwed if they don't start
thinking about how they're to reinvent
themselves I think so because I think
you know Kevin Kelley uh who is he's got
a great blog he's I've known him for a
long time he has this great quote and
he's a founding editor of Wired magazine
he has this great quote productivity is
for robots so so what that means is it's
not about like rushing around being as
productive as possible 20 hours a day
and some people say that that you have
to like work work work work work and
then you know reap the benefits later
you know what he's really saying with
productivity is for robots is that
everything um that is not about you
learning personally is going to
eventually be outsourced or automated
and so you kind of have to have create
your own have your own ideas about what
you want to be and what you want to do
and then you know work to to create it
and then eventually either outsource it
or move on so you know and of course Tim
Ferriss talks about this note in the
4-hour workweek where eventually he
started to automate his processes so he
moved to the work week down from 80
hours to four hours that was the premise
of that book but I think it's more it's
more happening on a corporate level on a
fortune 500 level where entire layers of
middle management and middle employees
and even the workers working at the
factory that's all being automated or
moved to another country what's going to
happen when self-driving cars are
driving everybody around it's 90 percent
of the auto industry is just going to
disappear and it's not like they're
going to be just transferred into the
self-driving industry that's going to be
a smaller industry so we all have to
reinvent themselves you're gonna have to
reinvent themselves that's just one
industry same things happening in
publishing in the music industry in
accounting in the legal industry the new
software's coming out that makes
everything simpler for accounting you
don't even you know yeah and also like
let's say let's say you and I were doing
a contract we're going to be partners in
some new business I don't need a lawyer
I'll go to a Legal Zoom download a
document and we'll sign it so so so many
things are happening now and companies
are catching up individuals are catching
up and you know hopefully the listeners
are catching up